a lot of relationships are strained
right now
husbands and wives not getting along
together yeah how about you how are you
guys but we've never been happier never
been happier everything's great
everything honey would you come in here
she's too happy to come in
she doesn't want just doesn't want to
come in you haven't laid eyes on her in
three days have you I can't remember
what she looks like donor
how about Liza how are you guys getting
along well Liza and I are doing pretty
well we're doing pretty well there was a
period there where it got bad where I
took lipstick and drew a face on a broom
and I was talking to that for awhile and
we actually our marriage flourished for
a while under those conditions the broom
and I but we're getting along so well
she swept you off your feet okay okay
girlie okay anything you need to fill
time do you have pets Conan I do I have
what K I got like they I have two dogs
would you like to meet my dog I'd like
to meet your dog yes
here he goes he's a little sleepy yeah
probably been watching our interview
there you go who is though this is Benny
and he looks good yeah yeah
how old is Benny eight and a half months
old he's still kind of a puppy yeah he
just yawned in my face it was it was a
huge blow to my ego that a dog has tired
of my high jinks
now I've proved that I have a dog I
don't can you prove that you have a pet
my dogs are I believe out in the yard so
I'd have to leave for your long period
of time I could go and get one of the
dogs and drag it up here if you have a
photo of your dog not here in the room
no why would you question whether or not
I have a dog who would lie about
something like that
I have a de who what who would lie about
having a dog yeah yeah sociopaths will
often lie about it to humanize
themselves
I don't have a dog
[Laughter]